the Russian military was in such a
terrible state as anyone who's traveled
with them no as I have knows you know
incredibly tired equipment on the you
know just this side of collapsing
entirely helicopters you know held
together with masking tape and etc you
know old equipment metallurgy from the
1950s in terms of aircraft engines etc I
you know Russia's rich enough if it
wants to to create a proper professional
army and obviously the all kinds of
announcements are being made uh just uh
where's began the thirtieth of March and
I think this week the defense ministers
office in Moscow announced of every five
new pursuit submarines capable of
launching proper missiles built in the
next few years if they carry through on
this if they demobilize this extremely
inefficient conscript army and replace
it with a proper volunteer professional
army they certainly have the means to do
so but so far don't think it's very
clear stationing a few bombers in Havana
or in in Caracas isn't going to change
anything that I and the Americans are
not the American Defense Department
under this Secretary of Defense under
robert gates are not so stupid as to use
this to panic over this that these
people are gates general Jones the
national security advisers Admiral
Mullen the chairman of the Joint Chiefs
these are very sophisticated people they
understand that a couple of two polyps
in Venezuela it can be shot down in
easily enough by I
by us anti-aircraft forces it I don't
think that's the problem I think the
question is whether the Russians intend
a to create out of the ruins of this
post Soviet Army a proper army and to
proper military season and to whether
what they did in Abkhazia and South
Ossetia is part of a more general plan
to recreate a zone of interest and
influence or whether these were just
specific actions having to do with the
very particular state of relations and
view toward Georgia that I don't have a
sense of
so I think the situation is really
terrible and I think the Obama
administration is late although I think
it's very much to their credit that
they've realized they were late and as a
result the Secretary of State Clinton
and the Homeland Security Secretary
Janet Napolitano and various senior
figures of the military are now down
there a lot no this is the gravest
threat to a latin american state since
the attempt by the colombian drug
cartels 15 years ago to do a similar
thing which was in effect to create a
free zone for themselves that the state
would would understand could not be
challenged that failed in Colombia but
only barely and I really only failed
definitively when President arriba came
into power and and most Colombians I
know would argue it failed because
everything else was tried that is say
the Pastrana government in Bogota tried
to negotiate both with the narco
traffickers quietly and with the FARC
guerillas publicly and that didn't work
and in the end there was a war and and
the Colombian state beat back this
fundamental challenge to its authority
not perfectly not the FARC still
controls vast swatches of Columbia and
may very well continue to do so for the
foreseeable future but at least the
high-water mark seems to have been
reached and and the tide is going out
again I think Mexico is very much in
that situation I think in the feet of
the border cities as well as in a few of
the resort cities there is an effort to
again create this kind of free zone and
whether the Calderon government is
strong enough to beat it back is is the
great question i mean in many ways
Mexico what happens in mexico is that
least is important and in my view more
important than what happens in packs